all right I'm Laura Ingram this is the
Ingram angle from a very busy Washington
tonight the Russia collusion
investigation meant to derail Trump's
2016 campaign was a complete and total
sham now today's special counsel John
Durham's conclusions weren't that brutal
and a matter of fact but his 306 page
report was blunt and damning now after
reading through as much of the report as
I could stomach tonight I was disgusted
and I was so sickened All Over Again by
what they did to Donald Trump what they
did to Carter page and so many others
along the way now we see in black and
white in facts presented what was
obvious and pervasive corruption now
there was clear political bias at work
Durham calls it confirmation bias in the
most powerful agencies within our
federal government intelligence and the
Federal Bureau of Investigation
now Hillary Clinton we know she skated
despite destroying evidence but Donald
Trump he was tormented over nothing
and this began never forget when Obama
was still in power
now here's a tidbit on the Steele
dossier which the FBI never corroborated
in footnote I love the footnotes 39. our
investigators uncovered little evidence
suggesting that prior to the submission
of the first Carter page fisa
application the FBI had made any serious
attempts to identify Steele's primary
sub Source other than asking steel to
disclose the identities of his sources
now further on page 13 regarding the sub
Source Igor donchenko donchenko was
unable to provide any corroborating
evidence to support the steel
allegations and further described his
interactions with his sub-sources this
is my favorite rumor and speculation
moreover notwithstanding the repeated
assertions in the Carter page fisa
applications that steals primary
subsources donchenko was based in Russia
donchenko for many years had lived in
Washington DC
but the FBI never corrected this
assertion in three subsequent page fisa
renewal applications rather beginning in
March 2017 the FBI engaged Don shenko as
a confidential human source and then
began making regular Financial payments
to him for information none of which
corroborated steals reporting at least
donchenko had a job
now this was a rotten operation from the
get-go
the speed and manner in which the FBI
opened and investigated Crossfire
hurricane during the presidential
election season based on raw unanalyzed
and uncorroborated intelligence also
reflected a noticeable departure from
how it approached prior matters
involving possible attempted foreign
intelligence interference plans aimed at
the Clinton campaign
you think
I do think I could have and should have
done a better job answering questions
earlier I really didn't perhaps
appreciate the need to do that what I
had done was allowed it was above board
it was totally above board everybody in
the government I communicated with and
that was a lot of people knew I was
using a personal email
destroy those blackberries with hammers
throughout this report then FBI director
Andrew McCabe and Deputy assistant
director for counter Intel Peter strzok
came off as pursuing Trump with a blind
zeal
in particular at the direction of McCabe
struck open Crossfire hurricane
immediately struck at a minimum had
pronounced hostile feelings toward Trump
the matter was opened as a full
investigation without ever having spoken
to the persons Who provided the
information
now after this conclusion by Durham
everybody watching tonight has to know
that it is important to remember how
Andrew McCabe described feeling right
after Comey was fired so sad this was at
his first meeting with President Trump
I was speaking
to the man who had just run for the
presidency and it she and and won the
election for the presidency
and who might have done so
with the aid of the government of Russia
our
most formidable adversary on the world
stage
and that was something that troubled me
greatly
you traveled my greatly epitome of
masculinity there now completely absurd
remember he knows they never
corroborated the dossier now more from
Durham FBI records prepared by strzok in
February and March 2017 showed that at
the time of the opening of Crossfire
hurricane the FBI had no information in
its Holdings indicating that any time
during the campaign anyone in the Trump
campaign had been in contact with any
Russian Intel officials
now despite the damning portrayal struck
he's still spinning
this is a predictable sad ending to an
investigation that never should have
taken place what we have here is John
Durham a U.S attorney taking a role
traditionally reserved for criminal
prosecutions and essentially writing a
four-year editorial for what he and Bill
Barr thought that Donald Trump wanted to
hear
oh does that mean he just wants to turn
the page
what a fraud
now this was rank abuse abuse of office
and a vindictive improper politically
motivated use of federal resources yet
Durham's conclusion was only that the
FBI failed to uphold their important
mission of strict Fidelity to the law
yeah it is outrageous that this happened
it is arguably worse than Watergate when
you look all the facts but the truth is
no one's going to do anything about it
now how do we know this
well I'd say look no further than how
the Press is treating the Biden family
money train now this last week right
Congressman Jim Comer put out all that
documentation all the bank records
showing money from foreign sources to
members of the Biden family what did the
media do hmm
Beyond
question
how did the bidens get so rich
I'm gonna ask it every night until the
election the Press is an interest in
finding the answer to that very simple
question are they
now the standard going forward after
everything that's happened it cannot be
that the government can use its power to
try to help liberal candidates for
office avoid prosecution and
accountability
as it relentlessly hounds conservatives
unspurious and totally made up grounds
all the while of course accusing the
target of lying so another day of
Hillary Clinton's emails and the Steele
dossier
this while the president of the United
States is lying about the FBI attacking
the FBI and attacking the rule of law in
this country
how does that make any sense at all
the rule of law
that guy should have won the Emmy best
actress in a dramatic series
oh sorry I didn't mean to say actress
FBI is an honest a political
organization I hope people will stare at
that and learn about what the FBI is
like human and flawed but deeply
committed to trying to do the right
thing
trying to do the right thing what a
prevaricating prig
that's not what Durham concluded but the
political class terrified of a bold
populist like Trump in office they did
everything they could to corroborate the
FBI instead of act as a legislative
check on it a check on its overreach one
word shiftless
there is direct evidence in the emails
from the Russians through their
intermediary offering dirt on Hillary
Clinton as part of what is described in
writing as the Russian government effort
to help elect Donald Trump there is
significant evidence much of it in the
public domain on the issue of collusion
and the Intel Community Chiefs with
their own reputations at stake they
circled the wagons and kept the farcical
defamatory story going
I will tell you that um
my dashboard warning light was clearly
on and I think that was the case with
all of us in the intelligence Community
very concerned about
the nature of these uh
approaches to the Russians if you put
that in context with everything else we
knew the Russians were doing to
interfere with the election
his his dashboard warning light was on
because they were about to be discovered
now additionally there were no nefarious
approaches to the Russians by Trump's
campaign and number two if the Russians
were interfering in the election the
evidence suggests that they were trying
to help Hillary via the phony steel
dossier
powerful forces in Washington powerful
forces and abroad were hell-bent on
destroying Donald Trump's political
career before it really began
these are the same forces who claimed to
this day to be the great Defenders of
democracy
but the truth all along was that they
were the real threats to democracy they
wanted to keep power by any means
necessary and they also wanted to send a
message to anyone like Donald Trump
anyone like him who comes along beware
Ronda santis might think about this
tonight because they will come for him
too in some way shape or form I promise
you that now why
they're going to do it because there are
no repercussions
this is also why Democrats will never
let go of January 6 because that's
another pretext for weaponizing the
federal government against the people
we all know there's next to no chance
that a group of what 500 right Wingers
are going to take down the entire U.S
government
and yet we also know that there is a
real possibility that in 2024 various
government agencies will try to
undermine our election process to ensure
only the acceptable people get elected
this is why today there's really not a
lot of trust in public institutions and
that's really sad
aside from election interference via
fake investigations look at what the
government's done they've destroyed our
energy Independence they've allowed
millions of foreigners to come here on
phony Asylum claims
this isn't a government we have right
now because they've embarrassed us they
act embarrassed of us on the world stage
no one's going to cut their funding on
Capitol Hill no one's going to lose
their cushy post-government jobs in fact
they'll probably get promotions in
Academia and in the media because they
did what they did
The Establishment always protects and
promotes its Heroes
the fact is you're not going to beat the
establishment in court sorry to report
you
but you have to beat them at the polls
if not we should expect more of the same
a government that acts more like an
occupying force that cavalierly abuses
the public trust whenever it senses
strong opposition hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else